MELISSA FRANCIS THANKS SO
MUCH.
LAST WEEK BRITISH VOTERS
WENT TO THE POLLS TO VOTE IN
THE EUROPEAN UNION ELECTIONS
AND THE RESULTS WERE A BIG
VICTORY FOR THE BRAND NEW
BREXIT PARTY.
THE BREXIT PARTY DEMANDS A
VERY SIMPLE THING THAT THE
BRITISH GOVERNMENT HONOR THE
2016 REFERENDUM TO LEAVE THE
EU.
BRITAIN WAS ALREADY SUPPOSED
TO BE OUT OF THE EU MONTHS
AGO BUT THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE
HAVE DRAGGED THEIR FEET AND
ARE NOW DEMANDING A SECOND
VOTE.
AS IN THE UNITED STATES, THE
DEMOCRACY IS ONLY WELCOME
WHEN IT CONFIRMS THE
POLICIES CHOSEN BY PEOPLE IN
POWER.
IN CASE YOU HAVEN'T NOTICED.
NIGEL FARAGE LEADS THE
BREXIT PARTY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
IF YOU COULD EXPLAIN FOR OUR
AUDIENCE THREE YEARS AFTER
BREXIT THE U.K. IS STILL IN
THE EU.
>> WE VOTED REFERENDUM TO
LEAVE THE EUROPEAN UNION.
THE MOST EVER IN THE HISTORY
OF OUR NATION.
WE THEN, THE NEXT YEAR, IN A
GENERAL ELECTION, VOTED FOR
LABOR AND CONSERVATIVE
PARTIES OUR TRADITIONAL
PARTIES.
BOTH OF WHOM PROMISED THEY
HAD WOULD HONOR THE RESULT
OF THE REFERENDUM.
AND THE DATE WAS SET.
IT WAS PUT INTO BRITISH LAW.
WE WERE LEAVING.
ON MARCH 29TH, 2019.
GUESS WHAT HAPPENED?
WE DIDN'T LEAVE.
AND THEY KICKED THE CAN DOWN
THE ROAD TO THE END OF
OCTOBER.
THE 31st OF OCTOBER.
HALLOWEEN.
AND I WATCHED ALL OF THIS AS
BEING ONE OF THE ARCHITECTS
OF THE ORIGINAL BREXIT
REFERENDUM AND VOTE.
AND I THOUGHT I CAN'T STAND
ASIDE.
I CAN'T BEAR THE FACT WE ARE
HAVING TO SEND MEMBERS OF
THE EUROPEAN PARLIAMENT BACK
TO BRUSSELS SO I FOUNDED THE
BREXIT PARTY.
WOULD YOU BELIEVE WITHIN SIX
WEEKS OF A BRAND NEW PARTY
BEING SET UP WE TOPPED THE
POLLS, WE SMASHED THE
CONSERVATIVE PARTY, WE
SMASHED THE LABOR PARTY, AND
REGRETTABLY I'M BACK HERE IN
BRUSSELS, TUCKER, AFTER 20
YEARS, ONCE AGAIN, AS A
MEMBER OF THE EUROPEAN
PARLIAMENT.
>> Tucker: I KNOW IT'S
COMPLICATED BUT EXPLAIN, IF
YOU CAN HOW IT IS A LIBERAL
OR PROGRESSIVE POSITION TO
REMAIN IN THE GERMAN EMPIRE
WHICH IS BASICALLY WHAT THE
EU IS.
WHY IS THAT CONSIDERED
LIBERAL?
>> BECAUSE THEY CLAIM THAT
AS A EUROPEAN UNION THEY
WILL DEAL WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THEY CLAIM THAT THE BECAUSE
THEY HAVE OPEN BORDERS THIS
IS THE MODERN LIBERAL
APPROACH TO THE FUTURE.
WHAT THEY DON'T TELL YOU IS
THEY ARE LITERALLY KILLING
AND DESTROYING SOMETHING.
SOMETHING SO IMPORTANT THAT
JUST NEXT WEEK WE'RE GOING
TO CELEBRATE THE 750TH
ANNIVERSARY OF D-DAY.
WHAT AMERICA AND CANADA AND
OTHERS CAME TO OUR AID,
HELPED US LIBERATE, YOU
KNOW, EUROPE FROM NAZIISM TO
BRING BACK SOMETHING CALLED
DEMOCRACY.
WHAT THE EUROPEAN UNION DOES
IS IT CRUSHES DEMOCRACY.
IT TAKES DECISION-MAKING
POWERS AWAY FROM ORDINARY
PEOPLE AND GIVES IT TO
UNELECTED BREWER DEMOCRATS.
>> Tucker: THE HEAD OF THE
EUROPEAN COMMISSION DOESN'T
APPEAR TO BE CUTTING YOU ANY
SLACK.
THERE IS A REMARKABLE QUOTE
JUST THE OTHER DAY.
I'M QUOTING NOW.
THE STUPID NATIONALISTS, HE
SAID, THEY ARE IN LOVE WITH
THEIR OWN COUNTRIES.
IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE PEOPLE
LIKE THIS HAVE LEARNED
ANYTHING FROM THESE VOTES.
>> NOPE.
NOPE.
THIS IS MR. JUNCKER, THAT'S
HIS QUOTE.
THE PEOPLE I BLAME AREN'T
NECESSARILY THE BRUSSELS
BUREAUCRATS.
THE PEOPLE I BLAME ARE
BRITISH POLITICIANS IN
WESTMINSTER WHO HAVE NOT HAD
THE COURAGE TO TAKE BACK THE
INDEPENDENT'S SOVEREIGNTY,
DEMOCRACY OF OUR COUNTRY.
LAST WEEK I HAVE GIVEN THEM
THE BIGGEST SEISMIC SHOCK
THAT HAS BEEN SEEN IN MODERN
BRITISH POLITICS AND I WILL
MAKE YOU THIS ONE PROMISE.
IF WE DO NOT LEAVE THE
EUROPEAN UNION, ON OCTOBER
THE 31st, I WILL LEAD THE
BREXIT PARTY AFTER THAT INTO
THE NEXT GENERAL ELECTION
AND WE WILL SWEEP AWAY
PARTIES THAT HAVE DOMINATED
BRITISH POLITICS FOR OVER
100 YEARS.
>> Tucker: WE COULD BE